I'm gonna ask this question and I know
the answer but it'll get us somewhere
sure did you see who did you see the
Bruce Lee documentary BB water I did not
see the glue stain have you watched last
days your ass much less dance yet uh no
because did you see the Lance Armstrong
one no those are two things but I'm
going to now here's the way what you say
you do I've seen be water I haven't seen
me water because it's gonna get I feel
like it's documentary about an actor but
I know it's more than that
it's so it's gonna get well it's he when
I was watching it that's why I want to
ask you watch it cuz I wasn't watching
it after my girl I go Bryan's gonna see
this and it's gonna validate his point
you know he's a childhood act about
stiii be good when he was for the
Chinese certain uh right or that was
Jackie Chan actually I was chair you
know his dad his dad was a business and
his dad put him in movies he had like
speaking always like four but he grew up
as a child actor star star yes he did he
died when he was 18 there he went to San
Francisco or I'm sorry when he was like
two months ago they came back since then
he came back to Hong Kong
yeah and then started movies and then
and they came out here to try making the
movies he's enacting his whole life
whole life and then he then what sorry
Robert wasn't his somebody in this
family was white am I wrong his wife his
mom his wife no is he is he he's white
as well yeah yeah he's my eyes mixed yes
but his mom's not all white she's mixed
okay yeah she's like half-asian
half-white dad straight-up hunk from
China
okay first time got but uh yes so but so
he was huge over and huge oh yes the
song is I'm making Hollywood goes to
Hollywood doesn't go great for him he
did get it he did land on the The Green
Hornet yep I remember very well it's
crazy how he got the Green Hornet he was
doing a demonstration in Long Beach and
there was a stylist there a haircut
Stassi was like oh this guy's great
and he cuts the hair of this big guy who
owns I think Warner Brothers he was
getting the guy who made decision that
Warner Brothers because I know you look
for an Asian actor fill the kilo or with
Aikido Kaito Kaito role this guy might
be good they bring him in and they show
his audition Jesus Christ
really well they didn't realize since he
was four he's been in front of the
camera oh yeah so they thought he was
just gonna
dude they bring him in and he's um they
bring him some why can't he just show
some of your moves and he just knows
what he's doing and it's like but he's
so like quick and they've never seen any
but it's I mean quick but he's so like
entertaining because he's doing he's
talking he's dropping these
philosophical lines on there like Jesus
Christ so he gets that and then the
ratings weren't going good if you've
ever watched him I've watched I think
I've watched every one of his episodes I
used to be obsessed it didn't have a lot
of lines a lot of times he's just
sitting there doing karate he wrote to
that he wrote to the director was like
hey the pitch should be good this he's
not a sidekick he's they're a team he
should have more lines they gave him
some lines when you realized the racism
he don't work god it's not oh my god
you're see how they describe an Asian
person in Breakfast at Tiffany's ha ha
ha they're doing this that's what a
gentle even with his girlfriend the time
is soon to be wife after that who's
white they went then he's like what the
[ __ ] dude oh it's so bad so so bad I
always have this super suspect super
suspect his son who died I know what
we're not the biggest conspiracy
theorist but when you look into that
even a son who Brandon Lee who died look
at that
yeah I know that's a white guy pretend
to be that's what they usually did it's
so humid day you know even in his son
Brandon Lee says you know he's murdered
by the the Chinese mafia and so he likes
it didn't the the excuse that he was
allergic to aspirin that makes sense
because his father took aspirin his
entire life I don't know I don't know
now he did get his sweat glands take it
out because he didn't like how much you
sweat on camera get sweat through his
pits and sustain his shirt because
sweating so much so you got those taken
out is that true in a weekend before
that yes a week before he died he had he
passed out because it's so hot because
he got a sweat clients reboot and so
when he died it was the hottest day of
the year he's doing all this stuff are
you sure he had a sweat clay
I don't strange what true strange but
true sweat glands rumen for his other
pits according reports Lee didn't have
them removed for any medical reasons or
because they're from excessive sweating
he did because I camera you like that we
also got circumcised that I think 18 or
19 20 22 well that's weird
why because you wanted more american or
american yeah now you also you know i
got all these weird rabbit holes where i
want the dark stuff about these people
so apparently he also liked the women he
did like the way most famous
in China that's right and then Assam
that's surprising they asked him if you
have any like either you know lock be
with your frame you knows a lot of
temptation and he goes he said I forget
his exact line but he goes you know I I
was bad but I was as bad as a lot of
other does well he was 33 than when he
died 32 okay so as young as [ __ ] at the
top of this game and yes and a handsome
every every woman liked him so yes some
woman drop wrote a book how she was his
sidepiece I believe that really write
down the best dick game in the world to
like every girl he's had sex was like
used to the best I've ever had
especially men are pleasers it's a good
point
so are women though so it's kind of you
know we're giving people great people
yeah it's a fast thing he was a pioneer
and it was acceptable to be essentially
derogatory and racist or whatever toward
Asian people certainly in my lifetime
certainly up through the 80s and I'm not
making excuses for be kidding you also
got to realize the Japanese they were
enemy right they were a harbor so my tag
when our teacher is Korean I mean I
remember like he would the way people
would treat you is just um you guys I
mean you guys are young but I'm sure you
tell it but your parent was any race
Tamera's for sure yeah being in Texas
mean not biggest Korean in the world
did you toss that was a chubby and small
back then so so they worse yeah yeah do
you deal with it
can I feel like no one [ __ ] where I
grew up I mean as long as we're willing
to fight like it's fine yeah Vietnamese
from what correct me if I'm wrong a lot
of times Vietnamese and the Cambodians
are in the caymans country with gang up
they'd be a being they'd run in in
groups and if you were gonna fight them
they were gonna fight you
yeah there's a lot of people who don't
like interact with Vietnamese people or
Cambodian people don't know is that
we're small people but we're feisty and
we're down in a fight oh [ __ ] the
biggest thing we're like little pit
bulls feel like you don't have the
personnel you get fun you know sometimes
a person how do you think I feel like no
oh no I never want to fight with anybody
but I think the voice like kind of sets
people off because they see me and
they're like oh she's young yeah and
then I have like a deep bass voice my oh
no but Koreans don't take any [ __ ]
either it's the ethnic
Chinese who have done so incredibly well
because their culture and by the way so
have the Chinese so of the Vietnamese
that they suffered no shortage of racism
but they have crushed it to the point
where obviously places like Harvard have
a class the pears are harvested like we
can't have this many Asians we gotta see
what else is interesting there's there's
racism inside Asia of quite Chinese
towards Koreans Japanese towards Koreans
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]